now to an urgent story about the rising
threat of political violence just
yesterday we heard testimony on capitol
hill from an official who received death
threats against his children from angry
trump supporters today also marks five
years since a gunman opened fire on
members of congress and staff on a
baseball field republican congressman
steve scalise was seriously wounded cbs
news has learned capitol hill police
investigated nearly 10 thousand threats
in just the past year scott mcfarland
shows us how america's incredi
increasingly toxic toxic politics are
also becoming more dangerous
a college graduate with a public health
degree sid mather of maryland had no
political or criminal history until he
broke the law by committing a felony
with his cell phone at that moment i let
my anger get the best of me weeks after
the 2020 election mather called his
congressman and left a voicemail saying
he knew where the congressman and his
family lived and that he would blow up
his office prosecutors deemed it a death
threat that warranted swift and serious
consequences mater says he was angry his
congressman was challenging the results
of the election you say your intention
was to voice your opinion you went a lot
farther than that i did i did in fact
like when i when i picked up the phone
and i was so infuriated at that time it
was an unfortunate thing that i did and
i'm very sorry mather is now serving a
sentence of home detention after
pleading guilty to a federal criminal
charge of communicating a threat this
man with zero history of political
activism or protest is part of a
fast-growing wave of threats under
investigation by federal authorities
that has only increased since the
january sixth attack on the capital u.s
capitol police report a spike in threats
against members of congress in 2021
investigations of threats were up 11
from the previous year when there were
nearly 9 600 of them that's more than
double the number from five years ago
lucky to be alive i know god definitely
took care of me that day
some threats have already resulted in
violence
a gunman opened fire and severely
wounded republican house whip steve
scalise at a baseball practice in
virginia in 2017 before capitol police
returned fire and killed the shooter
scalise who's been undergoing physical
therapy for years says there should be a
zero tolerance policy and rigorous
prosecution for threats including the
verbal ones clearly people and there's
got to be mental illness involved in it
the rage that that some people might get
where they think it's okay to take a
political difference and want to then go
and commit violence based on it and just
last week a man was arrested for
threatening to kill a supreme court
justice the man was found near justice
brett kavanaugh's maryland home with a
gun and a knife and is charged with
attempted murder threats of violence and
actual violence against the justice is
of course strike at the heart of our
democracy put your mask on
the southern poverty law center in
advocacy organizations as the
increasingly overheated and inflammatory
rhetoric of politicians is fueling a
combustible toxic environment
[Music]
you believe elected officials could do
more to denounce this yeah there's no
question that hearing from elected
officials that this is unacceptable
behavior that there are consequences for
embracing this kind of hate speech and
extremist ideology
that makes a difference just as the
failure to do that makes a difference
though it's not only politicians who
bear responsibility according to sid
mather who knows people must resist
going too far like he did i still think
about it every
day like when i wake up or when i'm
going to sleep it stays it's going to
stay with me forever basically just for
that one mistake for that one night
the u.s house sergeant-at-arms has
recommended more security cameras and
more security upgrades in the hometown
offices of members of congress when
they're not here at the capitol in
capitol police tell cbs news they're
trying to hire and deploy 280 more
officers by the end of the summer
gail
very scary times scott thank you very
much